he'll reject nation you gonna watch
Rambo this blood
John honey Rambo movies have you seen
I've seen clips of many of them but I've
only seen one and it was the last one
Rambo in some countries known as John
RAM I know I was taken aback when they
didn't call it that here well arguably
that's probably the one the only one you
need to watch that's a big argument
because the author of first blood said
that that one is the one that's most
tonally akin to the John Rambo character
and the overall mood of what he
originally envisioned the character to
be as see I'm keepin it real
this is intense I would say watch first
blood and the fourth one you kind of
skipped two and three okay I wonder how
many people are like screw this guy no
that's not the rabbit
I'm all about source material apparently
I like this whole franchise even part
three it's not a good look I even like
that one
[Music]
[Music]
that's the coolest tribute trailer I've
ever seen you know look how far we've
come my niece she was taken I thank you
I thought it was like let's get taken
let's put it just on the John Rambo
ranch here ya know some cartels or
whoever that is I wonder why they
decided to splice the footage back and
forth when we saw the trailer for the
first trailer when we saw Hobbes and
Shaw I looked at you and I was like if
this was a Rambo movie I would have no
idea until the title card came up other
than that it looked like just any other
Sylvester Stallone action flick that's
come out recently pull it to the head
too or something you think Al Pacino
this could have been out Pacino guys
really he was almost rampu he was almost
Ram it was almost making this movie so
much
can you imagine what Al Pacino now would
be in the corn after the time this
movie's got there's so much production
hell it's taken like almost ten whole
years to get off the Rambo franchise in
general is one of many struggles the
first book to get a deaf it took a long
time literally the only smooth one was
part two getting that off the ground
because they were like well first one's
a hit so let's just make another one and
then part three was a production
nightmare hell I heard Stallone's ego
was through the roof on that one then
John Rambo came out you know decades
later and he was completely humbled at
one point and one of the early drafts of
this was supposed to be a little bit
sci-fi where they would deal with you
know one of those genetically modified
super inspired by some book called
hunter that I think it was like a kin to
the first predator movie and then of
course they had that point where they
thought that we're gonna get a prequel
we're Stallone my directa cuz he talked
about that then they talked about
possibly doing yeah that is a television
show dude they should just hand off the
franchise to Michael B Jordan they
nightosphere [ __ ] with a young assassin
or whatever you know a young soldier who
wants to learn how to kick every ass
that would have been funny that would
yeah or it could be a girl I thought
they were gonna do something with oh man
all these facts I know and I'm totally
blanking on Richard Crenna
character named colonel remembered
recurred friend is activating the
colonel Oh
the colonel character in the first
thrift I've ever probably do something
with like oh he has a daughter or a son
or you know it's sort of spent something
like that every character who has
appeared in these other Rambo movies
let's just get all their attitudes and
yeah let's make it personal even more
personal I wonder if people will
actually watch this movie other than
hardcore Rambo that's me trying to flow
with my mispronunciation those rhymes
Rambo with the bimbo in the [ __ ] Lambo
and at one point one of their other many
giraffes he United with the author of
the first blood to do oh so you meant in
the story he meets the eye yeah he never
the author of first blood and they're
going to make this very as they
described it as soulful portrayal of
Rambo and as later years but the
producers like now we want to make this
back human trafficking human trafficking
all the way and that's the plot line
that I think we've settled on here
although in retrospect I kind of yet
whether in terms of showing this
flashback footage and seeing that most
of the action seems like it's gonna take
place on Rambo's ranch yeah it's gonna
be like look all that Rambo's ranch will
work perfectly
Rambo comes mostly this takes place on
Rambo's ranch and and the first blood is
it all takes place in a small town while
it sound like one building it's still
pretty contained in terms of where the
action is whereas like two three and
four are just big war zones that it
takes place in and then this would bring
it back a little bit more to a contained
environment something I guess a little
bit more primal and
immediate and you know yeah more
contained
which I guess sounds pretty cool I just
have a hard time imagining people are
honestly all that hype for this movie or
do you guys hype for this movie I don't
know who's hyped for this film yeah I
mean I haven't heard anybody to talk
about or tweet about like that Katy this
is true JD just loves happy birthday by
the way
happy but I get the sense that this
trailer is partially trying maybe to use
that nostalgia you know splicing in old
clips to kind of play up that like oh
it's special it's probably the last
Rambo movie yeah um to kind of get
people more interested but yeah I don't
know this feels something more first
alone in company than it does feel for
like a fan base that's in need of
another Rambo he said he wouldn't mind
continuing on but then he also had
interviews where he said that he he just
felt like his body's not capable of
doing this anymore then he signed on to
do this yeah I feel like with the Creed
franchise he's not fighting in it so it
makes sense how he's able to still
sustain you know portrayal of rocky in
there but here it's like you know he
needs to be there unless this ends with
his daughter who's gonna be the new
Rambo
Jane Rambo is where people are gonna be
excited for that I mean I mean I'm
actually kind of bummed though because
that like soulful take sounds kind of
cool to me yes old full Rambo nah man
human trafficking that's where the
money's at yeah let's let's say
something good pop it let's have Rambo
jack up a bunch of Mexicans provide
relating commentary on trafficking let's
just kill a bunch of em kill a bunch of
cartel get that empathetic satisfy and I
heard this is having an early screening
at the White House
really and he's fighting mega is no
longer dropping room diving and dude
that's very American thing
that's green Rambo of the White House
well guys are you excited for Rambo last
blood will be seeing this it looks
Pleasant I wonder if it's gonna be as
gruesome tonally as the last one was
felt very real it doesn't look like
it'll necessarily feel real but it looks
like it will be brutal alright guys well
you guys to subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
you can check us on patreon where we do
a TV show reaction stream along some
with reaction highlights and queued
eluded let's give a patron the day shout
out to a fairly new patron just like
four or five days ago he pledged his
name is Omar young Omar is originally
from Puerto Rico he had moved to Florida
in pursuit of the big American Dream
yeah yeah I get your accents right I'm
sorry I'm sorry he's younger than us 23
years old already married it has a
beautiful hot wife who is sexually
satisfies morning noon and night I don't
know why he led with that when he first
introduced that's that I was like okay
Omar why not he's you're wondering his
wife is from Mexico so this trailer is
just for a cup of tea right I figured
this is the right channel of show you
own him don't worry Omar in the next
Rambo movie he's gonna fight Porto
Ricans you are gonna be demographically
satisfied you're gonna feel that
representation and you're gonna feel
great about it but you know what I just
want to say thanks for being here cuz
you seem like lovely cat yes and you
feel like you should watch this movie in
Spanish like you watched all 22 MCU
movies in Spanish like this well I feel
like there's probably a lot less dubbing
you know in Rambo movie you know and
then the occasional dialogue keep up
with the photography and videography
business my Frankie following that
passion much love to you and thanks for
being here